so today we're going to talk about three
weird symptoms of a fatty liver okay let
me first talk about the function of the
liver and what it does that's a lot of
different functions these are the main
ones it helps you make bile
what's bile bile is like the detergent
that helps break down fast to the point
where you can start pulling out of fat
the necessary fat soluble vitamins the
necessary essential fatty acids omega-3
fatty acids and then it doesn't break it
down a hundred percent just breaks it
down to a certain degree and then the
pancreas releases lipase which is the
other enzyme that breaks it down even
further so we now have the basic unit so
we can start using these necessary
elements from our food so they're more
functional so if there's liver problems
and you can't make enough bile you're
gonna have not just under nested fat but
you're gonna have unavailable that type
of vitamins leading to a whole cascade
of issues number two it helps you make
proteins a lot of different types of
protein lipoproteins which carry
cholesterol as an HDL and LDL also
protein in your blood the liver also
makes cholesterol makes quite a bit like
a thousand milligrams every single day
the liver can also make glucose as in
gluconeogenesis making new glucose and
it can make it from fat or protein and
it actually makes and helps you store
glycogen what's glycogen it's the
storage form of glucose it can turn
ammonia to urea which is a less toxic
substance ammonia is a byproduct of
protein metabolism the liver helps you
detoxify certain things chemicals
poisons drugs and there's certain
enzymes called phase 1 phase 2
detoxification where you're you're
turning these fat soluble toxic poisons
into water-soluble
harmless particles so the body can get
rid of them it also helps you buffer
excessive hormones so if there's too
much estrogen for example it can help
regulate that too much cortisol it can
actually help degrade cortisol so you
don't have excessive
so it really does a lot very very
important so what are the three weird
symptoms of a fatty liver when you have
a fatty liver you lose the capacity of
the liver to function okay so one of the
weird symptoms would be heart pain
you wouldn't think heart pains
associated with the liver but when you
actually have fat in the liver and even
cirrhosis the liver starts to enlarge to
a certain degree and there's not a lot
of space in there so it can compress
over to the heart especially if you're
laying on your left side because the
liver is on the right side and the
hearts on the left so if you lay down it
can compress on that heart so it's best
if you have this problem sleep on your
right side it'll be much better so if
you get heart symptoms but the heart is
fine have them check the liver alright
number two gynecomastia what is that man
boobs why do you get that because you
can't filter out excessive amounts of
estrogen and it's just too much estrogen
in a male body another symptom of too
much estrogen would be spider veins as
well all right number three night
blindness now night blindness is a
vitamin A deficiency how would you
become deficient about M&A well you're
actually not making enough bile because
the liver makes the bile the gallbladder
stores the bile if you don't have enough
you can't absorb vitamin A and vitamin A
is not just involved in night blindness
it's involved in vision in general so
you're just gonna find your vision is
just poor and it's coming from a liver
problem all right here's some other
symptoms of a fatty liver high
cholesterol decrease bile and what
happens if you don't have a bile you
can't break down the cholesterol so it's
really the bile production that is
necessary to regulate cholesterol belly
fat and by the way I have five patients
who I sent to the radiologist to get
ultrasounds and five out of five had a
fatty liver so if you have a gut you
might want to get a scan and the scan I
would recommend is called fiberscan
fiberscan is something that your
doctor can do to assess not just a fatty
liver but if there's any scar tissue or
fibrosis
okay it's an ultrasound test and it can
pick that up in certain levels I think
it's a really good test and ultrasound
is not like any radiation so it's pretty
safe all right next one
diabetes so if the liver loses its
capacity to help you with blood sugars
this can be one of the results fatigue
is a very common symptom of a fatty
liver right shoulder pain and not just
right on the right shoulder pain but in
the right neck and the jaw and the back
of the trap up here and the right
rhomboid in the back part by your
scapula to the right of your midline of
your spine it seemed okay so on the
bottom of the feet and the palms of the
hand you can get redness in the palm of
the hand as well confusion irritability
why because you have blood sugar issues
bad breath okay so that's another
symptom alright there's a couple last
things I want to bring up about a fatty
liver number one gastric bypass
can increase your risk of getting a
fatty liver especially if you don't have
enough bile which I think that's the
reason because they're altering the
digestive system to a certain degree
extreme low protein diets can cause a
fatty liver now you would think would be
just the opposite but if you're very low
on protein the body could actually
create fat in the liver which is
interesting certain drugs steroids
tamoxifen there's a whole series of
drugs that can create a fatty liver
viruses can create a fatty liver but the
most common cause of a fatty liver is
high levels of insulin because the
person is consuming too many
carbohydrates okay if you're new to my
channel I put a link down below of
exactly what eating plan you should be
on to reduce your carbs so you can get
the fat out of the liver and there's one
vitamin that's a very very important for
a fatty liver and that is choline okay
choline actually can help you take the
fat off the liver I'll put a link down
below on a video where I talk about
choline thanks for watching
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg.com it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out